so the scottish parliament now has a
pro-independence majority
elected by the people of scotland will
the uk government respect that and grant
a
independence referendum
well the first thing to say is you're
quite right that nicolas sturgeon
and the scottish national party got the
largest number of seats uh in this
election so my congratulations
to nicola and her team on their result
and also my congratulations
to others who've been elected in the
scottish parliamentary elections we now
have a more
diverse team uh in holyrood representing
different parties and
different communities than ever before
and that's a a good thing a sign that
democracy
is strong and resilient and growing but
the
priority i think for politicians not
just in hollywood but across the united
kingdom at the moment
has to be recovery from the pandemic and
nicolas sturgeon herself made clear
during the campaign that her first
priority her top priority
would be working to make sure that we
can come out of this pandemic and
recover
that is as you say exactly the same
thing as s p been saying they've said
that they want to focus on the recovery
from covid
they've said that now isn't the time to
push immediately
for a referendum on the independence but
that wasn't quite my question about the
timing
i'm asking if the principle of a second
referendum on independence is something
that the uk government would grant
because right now
if you look at the snp and if you also
look at the scottish greens
who are another pro-independence party
there is a clear majority
for independence in the scottish
parliament if they pass legislation
in order to move to another referendum
would you block it
uh no what we're concentrating on doing
at the moment is making sure that we
work together to deal with all of the
challenges
that uh we face across the whole united
kingdom now
my mum will have woken up this morning
in aberdeen
and the first question on her mind will
not have been will we or won't we have
an independence referendum will we or
won't we have
another few years of wrangling over the
constitution the first question in my
mom's mind will be
what about my grandson and
granddaughter's education
what about the nhs care that my family
need
what about the jobs that i hope that my
grandchildren
will go on to enjoy those are the
priorities at the moment
and if we get sucked into a conversation
about referenda constitutions and all
the rest of it
then we're diverting attention from the
issues that are most
important to people in scotland and
across the united kingdom
and i think i hope that what people want
from the holyrood government
and also from the westminster government
as a commitment to work together
on these issues so instead of
concentrating on the things that divide
let's concentrate on the things that
unite and let's concentrate on
all of us working together to serve the
people who just voted for us
i'm sorry to you i'm not asked if i'm
not asking the questions that she most
wants uh to be answered
um but the question that i am asking is
if the scottish parliament passed
she still watches sky anyway well that's
good um i'm happy to hear
that um if the scottish parliament does
pass a bill to in to hold a referendum
how will you react will you take it to
court
well i i think how i would react how the
people of scotland
uh would react to any attempt to bring
forward legislation like that you would
react
is a spokesperson for the uk government
well i think i think most people would
react
by thinking hold on a moment you're
really saying that the priority
when we we still have this vaccination
program that we need to rule out when
young people need their uh
jabs in their arms when we we
acknowledge that people have spent
months out of school with learning lost
and
uh with their opportunities as a result
occluded do you think that people are
really going to say
do you know what what we really really
want is legislation
on a referendum um uh it's it's
to my mind uh i'll put it gently a
slightly skewed set of priorities to
imagine
that that is the most important issue
indeed as i say during the course of
this campaign
uh nicholas turgeon to her credit said
that the most important thing
was uh making sure that we dealt with
this pandemic and that's what we're
we're laser focused on and one of the
reasons that i'm here in glasgow
is that uh the the cabinet office the
government office and the uk government
uh that i work for is uh has a new
headquarters here
so that we can work alongside local
authorities the nhs
and others in order to show two
governments working
together um and my sense actually is
that for a lot of people who voted snp
the one
thing that they wanted was continuity in
dealing with the pandemic
and concentrating on that it's a very
specific
question if the scottish parliament
passes legislation
to move towards another independence
referendum will the uk government
block it in the courts
no we're not even going there at the
moment what we're concentrating on
is making sure that we work on uh
recovery
um if they pass a bill to hold a
referendum
will the uk government take it to the
supreme court
we're not going to go there what i'm
going to do is to make sure that we do
everything we can to concentrate and
focus on recovery because again
you know during the course of the uh the
election debates nicola sturgeon
uh graciously acknowledged uh that uh
the scottish government made some
mistakes
in the past um in particular she said
that they'd taken their eye off the ball
when it came to dealing with the
terrible problem of drug deaths here in
scotland
um it's our responsibility to make sure
that no one in hollywood
takes their eye off the ball when it
comes to dealing not just with drug
deaths
but also with the uh the backlogs that
have been generated in public services
and the pandemic
and also the economy so to to go down
this route to start speculating about
this type of legislation or that type of
court hearing and all the rest of it
it's just a massive distraction um and
as i say i
cannot believe that uh uh people who are
uh worried about their jobs worried
about the extension of furlough uh
worried about what's happening
uh to their children's education i
cannot believe that they think
that the answer to all of these things
is a
protracted debate on the constitution um
we all know that what we need is urgent
focused action on that
so you know i'm i'm i'm not interested
in
uh going down that blind alley what i
am determined to do is to work with
nicola and her team and of course mark
drakeford
uh to whom i also offer my
congratulations re-elected as the first
minister of wales
in dealing with the immediate problems
we face you're talking about not wanting
to
go down this blind alley you're saying
this is not what voters care about
but the very reason that i'm asking
these questions is because on thursday
the people of scotland elected a
majority of
msps to their parliament who clearly are
in favor
of a independence referendum that's how
democracy works isn't it that's why
we're talking about it that's why it's
on the table
if they pass legislation and ask you for
a third time
if they pass legislation to move towards
another independence referendum
will the uk government block it in the
courts
well if we look at what happened during
that campaign
uh it's important to recognize the
issues that were raised and the
questions that were asked
and when nicola sturgeon was on at the
bbc and she was asked
what would you say to someone who didn't
want an independence referendum
but thought that you first minister were
the right person to steer scotland
through the next stage of the pandemic
and she said unhesitatingly i would tell
that person to vote
for me so uh i again nicola herself is
uh acknowledged and again i think it's
it's gracious of her to do so
that there are people who will have
voted for her because they want her to
carry on
uh with uh pandemic cooperation the
spirit of continuity
in that area and who are not putting
independence first the other thing of
course is that
if we look at the votes cast if you look
at the votes casting constituencies in
scotland
uh more people voted for parties that
were uh
opposed to an independence referendum
than those that might entertain that
prospect
so again i think it's it's critically
important to look
at uh at this debate in context
and and again uh one of the things that
uh i think we should all be focusing on
and citizens expect us to focus on
are what are our plans in order to
improve delivery in the nhs
in education in criminal justice in all
of the areas
that matter most to voters nobody denies
that during this campaign that the
number one issues
were health and the economy and that's
what people expect us to focus on
are there any circumstances where boris
johnson might agree to a second
independence referendum
well it's not an issue for the moment um
and of course
the people of scotland uh uh as we saw
uh
in the referendum in 2014 they have that
right
but it is absolutely important that we
concentrate
now on the issues in front of us
um and of course you know one of the
things to bear in mind is that while
nicola sturgeon
obviously secured a good result the snp
did not get a majority
in this election as they did um in 2011
uh in 2011 the the snp under uh alex
hammond
got a majority a referendum then
followed it's important to remember that
at that time every party in the scottish
parliament
thought that it was appropriate to hold
a referendum then the snp did not get a
majority
in this election and also critically
we we had a campaign in which all of the
party leaders acknowledged
that the single most important thing was
dealing
with the pandemic and i think that uh a
movement away from that
would be something that voters would i
you know i i think they'd feel
well disappointed to put it mildly that
we were not concentrating on their
priorities and at the same time though
the reason that we're talking about this
is because there is a pro-independence
majority in the scottish parliament
if you look at the scottish national
party and also the scottish greens
you're talking about people voting for
many different reasons not everyone
uh backing and nicola sturgeon purely on
independence
i'm sure of course people do vote for
different things but you know we're
talking about the scottish national
party here i mean it's not exactly
as if they've they've hidden their
support for another independence
referendum under a bush is it
um well to be fair uh they certainly
haven't put it front and center
in the shop window tied up with a big
bow and said this is our major offer
quite the opposition uh again to be fair
yes and to be fair the uh uh the snp
and the uh uh and the first minister
made it clear that their priority
um was to deal with the the pandemic um
and
indeed again to be fair uh to the first
minister and the snp
uh weekend week out i meet with nicola
sturgeon
mark drakeford and of course arlene
foster and michelle o'neill from
northern ireland
to discuss how we can work together and
in private
uh we we have a uh i i hope
uh nicola would agree a business-like
and effective
relationship in making sure that we can
uh work together
overcome our divides and make sure that
the people of the united kingdom
benefit from that joint working so
uh yes of course uh uh the the snp has
a set of policies and a set of
traditions but they also have
a responsibility at the moment which uh
their first minister
has outlined to concentrate on
recovery and again we have a queen
speech coming up
um in the westminster parliament in just
a few days time
at its heart um are a series of bills
and measures which will strengthen our
nhs
um and again i think if you were to ask
most people in glasgow if there was
going to be a conversation between
the prime minister and the first
minister would you like that
conversation to be about the
constitution or would you like that
conversation to be about getting
hospitals to do a better job additional
support for doctors and nurses
dealing with the drug death problem that
we have here um i think if you had a
referendum on the question of whether or
not they should be talking about the
constitution or the nhs
i think it would be the nhs by a
landslide and that's what we need to do
well let's talk a bit about um the
conversations that are going to be had
between the prime minister and the first
minister because
boris johnson has invited nicolas
sturgeon to his summit with other
first ministers of course this is going
to be a lot about you know the covert of
recovery and the pandemic but do you
expect independence to be discussed
there as well
well i i would hope not um because the
purpose of it is to make sure that we
work together on the on the on the
pressing issues that face us
now of course uh uh uh nicola sturgeon
mark drakeford um ali and foster
michelle o'neill um
may well want to raise um uh you know
individual issues
quite right too it's a broad inclusive
conversation but the aim of the
conversation
is to see how we can work together even
better um as i mentioned briefly earlier
but we have been cooperating to deal
with the pandemic
um we can also learn from one another
one of the things about devolution
is that you can have as they have had in
scotland wells a slightly different
approach
tailored to the unique circumstances of
each country
but under the broad umbrella of a
uk-wide strategy
and in that conversation one of the
things that we can do is
both learn from each other's experience
over the last year
but also develop a shared understanding
of where our priorities need to be
in the future how can we use the broad
shoulders of the uk treasury
in order to ensure that uh there is the
right investment
in the nhs and scotland and the right
support for scottish students to catch
up on their education
um let's talk a bit about the uh what
happens next with the recovery from the
pandemic because we're told that the
queen's speech is going to be focusing
on
you know building back one of the areas
that has been
really hit hard by kevin 19 is care
homes
an area of course where the the
difficulties
in that particular sector have also been
very much exposed
by the pandemic too now when he became
prime minister
boris johnson said i'm announcing now on
the steps of downing street that we
fixed the crisis in social care once and
for all with a clear plan we have
prepared
now this mysterious clear plan seems
like it's never really appeared are we
going to finally get a glimpse of it
yes we'll be saying more about social
care in the weeks and months to come
you're absolutely right it's a it's a
huge issue um uh
with an aging population with uh
the particular challenges that uh
dementia alzheimer's and
and other conditions pose we do need to
make sure that we improve the operation
of our social care system
we also know that while there are some
outstanding care providers
people like robert kilgauer and others
it's also the case
uh that there are some settings which do
not maintain the high standards that
we'd want
so we need to look at funding we need to
look at an inspection
we need to look at how we can make sure
that we get the investment required
we need to look at how we can improve
quality and helen waitley the care
minister and matt hancock the secretary
of state
have been developing a plan on this and
we'll be saying more in due course
absolutely
you say say more in due course what does
that mean is it going to be in the queen
speech
well the queen's speech will be
concentrating on particularly
how we can improve the uh the operation
of the nhs
uh the additional funding that will be
required in order to deal with the
immediate problems that we face
uh we've got a significant backlog in
the nhs
well we'll be seeing more in the
immediate aftermath well
one thing i can't do is reveal
everything that's going to be in the
queen's speech
um i mustn't preempt her majesty at the
same time i
understand you don't you can't reveal
everything but you know we were told two
years ago that there was a clear plan
ready to go
still no sign of it
well people i think will appreciate that
we've been concentrating
quite rightly um on the uh immediate
challenges posed by the pandemic
people will also expect of course a new
plan for social care to be developed
um and that plan uh will be unveiled
later this year
okay i'm talking about curving 19 uh
public health england this week
elevated one version of the indian
variant so-called
indian variant to a variant of concern
how worried are you about this and could
it slow
down the easing of the road map
well i'm genuinely worried as everyone
should be about
uh the instance of variance of concern
but there's no indication at the moment
that it needs slow down the relaxation
that we have
as part of the roadmap um the promise
we'll be saying more about this
uh this week one of the things that we
do do is that we have a
a very effective testing regime we make
sure that whenever we
we note a spike in the instance of any
variant of concern
that we surge testing into that area uh
there are other options available to us
in order to make sure that we can
control the spread and the rate of
infection in those areas
but overall thanks to the success of the
uk vaccination program
and also the good sense of people across
the united kingdom we can progressively
relax
uh measures so uh i anticipate that the
prime minister
tomorrow uh will signal that uh we can
enter the next stage of relaxation
uh in england on may the 17th um and as
the transport secretary indicated
yesterday
that means also that uh some of the
rules on international travel are
changing as well
talk about those rules on international
travel and what should happen to the
champions league final
do you think it should be held in the uk
now that turk has been put on the
red list well i'm party pre here
because my son is a chelsea fan um and
he would dearly love to see the game
played
in the uk but there are delicate
negotiations that are going on at the
moment
um uh my my friend my colleague the
culture secretary oliver dowden
is talking to people um about this at
the moment um and so i don't want to cut
across that
but i'm sure that um uh uh fans in the
uk would dearly love to see the
the final played here um in the uk
uh just finally and we're going to be
talking to diane abbott shortly
also in murray of the shadow cabinet
soon it's been a very difficult
set of elections for the labour party in
england who do you think should carry
the can for it the
leader or the party chairman
well i i i don't wish to intrude on
internal debates and the
in the labour party people go into
public life people go into politics
because they want to serve and so
um you know uh ian murray diane abbott
uh kirsten or others uh well i may
disagree with them on lots of issues
uh they want to do the best for their
country so um i i
i can't comment about those sorts of
things um i'm sure that ian and diane
will have far more interesting things to
say about that than than i could
possibly have
uh is it helpful to have a strong
opposition for democracy
yes okay michael gave
thank you very much one of your famous
one-word answers there much appreciated